but i got to ask you about geometry and
it's a prominent
topic in your new book shape so for me
geometry is the thing just like as
you're saying made me fall in love with
mathematics when
i was young so being able to prove
something
visually just did something to my brain
that
it had this it planted this hopeful seed
that
you can understand the world like
perfectly
uh maybe it's an ocd thing but from a
mathematics perspective
like humans are messy the world is messy
biology is messy
your parents are yelling or making you
do stuff but
you know you can cut through all that bs
and truly understand the world through
mathematics and
nothing like geometry did that for me
for you
you did not immediately fall in love
with geometry so
uh how do you how do you think about
geometry
why is it a special field in mathematics
and
uh how did you fall in love with it if
you have wow you've given me like a lot
to say and
certainly the experience that you
describe is so
typical but there's two versions of it
um you know one thing i say in the book
is that geometry is the cilantro of math
people are not neutral about it there's
people who are like who like you
are like the rest of it i could take or
leave but then at this one moment
it made sense this class made sense why
wasn't it all like that there's other
people i can tell you because they come
and talk to me all the time
who are like i understood all the stuff
we were trying to figure out what x was
there's some mystery or trying to solve
it x is a number i figured it out but
then there was this geometry like what
was that
what happened that year like i didn't
get it i was like lost the whole year
and i didn't understand like why we even
spent the time doing that
so um but what everybody agrees on is
that it's somehow different
right there's something special about it
um
we're gonna walk around in circles a
little bit but we'll get there you asked
me
um how i fell in love with math
i have a story about this um
when i was a small child i don't know
maybe like i was six or seven i don't
know
um i'm from the 70s i think you're from
a different decade than that but
you know in the 70s we had um you had a
cool wooden box around your
stereo that was the look everything was
dark wood uh and the box had a bunch of
holes in it
to lift the sound out yeah um and the
holes
were in this rectangular array a six by
eight array
um of holes and i was just kind of like
you know zoning out in the living room
as kids do
looking at this six by eight rectangular
array of holes
and if you like just by kind of like
focusing in and out just by kind of
looking at this box looking at this
rectangle
i was like well there's six rows of
eight holes each
but there's also eight columns of six
holes each whoa
so eight sixes and six eights it's just
like the dissection bruce we were just
talking about
but it's the same holes it's the same 48
holes that's how many there are no
matter of whether you count them
as rows or count them as columns and
this was like
unbelievable to me am i allowed to cost
on your podcast i don't know if that's
uh are we fcc regulated okay it was
[ __ ] unbelievable okay that's the
last time get it in this story merits it
so two different perspectives and the
same physical reality
exactly and it's just as you say um
you know i knew that six times eight was
the same as eight times six when i knew
my times tables like i knew that that
was a fact
but did i really know it until that
moment that's the question
right i knew that i sort of knew that
the times table was symmetric
but i didn't know why that was the case
until that moment and in that moment i
could see like oh i didn't have to have
somebody tell me that
that's information that you can just
directly access that's a really amazing
moment and as math teachers that's
something that we're really trying to
bring
to our students and i was one of those
who did not love
the kind of euclidean geometry ninth
grade class of like
prove that an isosceles triangle has
equal angles at the base like this kind
of thing it didn't
vibe with me the way that algebra and
numbers did um
but if you go back to that moment from
my adult perspective looking back at
what happened with that rectangle i
think that is a very geometric moment in
fact that moment
exactly encapsulates the
the intertwining of algebra and geometry
this algebraic fact that
well in the instance 8 times 6 is equal
to 6 times 8 but
in general that whatever two numbers you
have you multiply them one way and it's
the same as if you multiply them in the
other order
it attaches it to this geometric fact
about a rectangle which in some sense
makes it true so you know who knows
maybe i was always faded to be an
algebraic geometer which is what i am as
a
as a researcher
you